the Denmark's prime minister says
Greenland is not for sale even though
President Trump admits he did discuss
the idea of buying the Danish territory
the Prime Minister's word for the
conversation absurd but mr. Trump said
he does consider the Danes to be very
good allies nonetheless Greenlaw
Greenland meanwhile is also the focus of
scientists and in this morning's eye on
earth we're learning more about the
challenges facing the huge island it's
ice sheet is melting six times faster
now than in the 1980s this month alone
it lost eleven billion tons of surface
ice in just one day enough to fill more
than 4 million Olympic sized swimming
pools Seth Doane is there summer came
earlier this year and is expected to
last longer Greenlanders say they've
seen more extreme weather and fishermen
are catching warmer water fish they're
living climate change here and
scientists have come from around the
world to study why NASA built its
reputation on exploring the unknown but
it's scientists on this mission fly at
an altitude of just hundreds of feet
probing the depths not of space but the
sea each one of these has an instrument
that tells us the temperature and the
saltiness of the water Josh Willis of
NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory is in
year four of a five-year research
project he designed
we joined Saturday on a nearly seven
hour flight covering more than 800 miles
they're dropping probes into the ocean
to understand how the waters around
Greenland are warming and contributing
to the melting of glaciers we usually
think of Greenland's ice as sort of an
ice cube with a hairdryer on it but in
fact that ice cube is sitting in a pot
of water - and the water is warming up
as well and the two things together can
combine to create sea level rise that
happens much more rapidly than we
originally anticipated
Willis named his program oceans melting
Greenland
it's acronym oMG was no mistake he says
humankind should be surprised and pay
attention big picture what is all of
this
well it means Greenland's melting
there's enough ice at Greenland to raise
sea levels by 25 feet worldwide now we
don't think it'll happen right away but
just how fast it does is something we're
trying to figure out with oMG the icy
environment can make it tough to drop
the probes but does offer some perks
stunning scenery this feels like a
remote place but what is happening here
has a real impact of average American
well that's right we all live with one
ocean so a billion tons of ice lost here
in Greenland means higher sea levels in
Florida California New York even as far
as Australia so far these missions have
shown them how sensitive these glaciers
are to the ocean
they've also produced a better map of
the seafloor which allows them to gauge
which glaciers are under threat the
answer more than they thought for CBS
this morning Seth Doane kulusuk
Greenland
all right Seth oMG certainly gets here G
Sanford this oceans melting Greenland by
omg and oMG could be trouble nicely done